l'ambiance est très très étrange ici
akif ce que vous pouvez voir derrière
moi c'est l'une des plus grandes artères
du centre ville du centre ville de kiev
où la circulation a été entièrement
coupée pour pouvoir exposer ses chars
ses camions militaires qui ont été mis
hors service par les ukrainiens donc ce
sont ces du matériel militaire russe
donc c'est une exposition qui intervient
à quelques jours vous l'avez dit du 24
août de ce jour national c'est une des
masses démonstration de force que
veulent montrer les autorités
ukrainiennes
ici au moment où vous l'avez dit le
président volodymyr zelensky est assez
inquiet dans ses allocutions quotidienne
et l'a dit et répété ce jour est très
symbolique c'est évidemment le jour de
l'indépendance de l'union soviétique
vous l'avez dit mais ça marquera
également les six mois de la guerre
contre la russie alors le président
volodymyr zelensky est très inquiet il
l'a fait savoir et puis les autorités
apprennent des mesures le couvre-feu qui
normalement est à 23h et bien va se
renforcer dans de nombreuses villes et
si actif le métro qui d'habitude
fonctionne jusqu'à 9h30 va être réduit à
21h impossible d'emprunter les
transports en commun ce métro qui
servira de potentiel abris antiaériens
en cas de frappes et puis les réunions
les les manifestations et les grands
rassemblements sont interdits jusqu'au
25 donc voyez il est quand même une
préoccupation il faut savoir également
que ce 24 août et bien marque un autre
anniversaire ont en tout cas une date
importante puisque les renseignements
ukrainiens prétendent que ce sera le
jour que va choisir la russie pour
organiser un procès à marioupol dans
cette ville occupée le procès de
prisonniers de guerre de lusine azoff ce
talent qui a été sous siège pendant
trois mois et où les militaires
ukrainien et bien on finit par se rendre
ils ont été arrêtés ils ont ils sont
depuis emprisonné et selon les autorités
ukrainiennes et bien ce serait
l'occasion pour la russie d'organiser un
procès un simulacre de procès dénonce
les autorités ukrainiennes volodymyr
zemsky qu'il a dit si véritablement il y
à un procès le jour de la fête fiona les
biens il n'y aura plus aucune
possibilité de discussion d'accord de
paix avec la russie